lots of site you might expect at one of
Australia's most popular tourist sites
visitors to the Blue Mountains west of
Sydney are forced to wear face masks as
a smoke from nearby bush fires fills the
air the iconic rock formations are
barely visible in the haze it's really
disappointing so we're really looking
forward to seeing the view and I've
always wanted to see the Blue Mountains
so such a shame that when we've came but
that problem is small compared to the
challenge firefighters in New South
Wales are set to face at the weekend
after a brief respite during a few days
of damper weather over Christmas
temperatures are again expected to soar
bringing new risks that's going to bring
not just the heat out of the centre of
Australia we're going to see the
temperatures up into the low to mid
forties across a lot of areas but it's
going to bring a very dry air as well so
that's going to elevate fire dangers and
we know the winds are going to start
turning around to the west and the
Northwest which is why so much work has
been going on over this last week while
conditions are more mild some 70 fires
are burning near Sydney in New South
Wales more than 1,000 firefighters are
now the military are in action across
the state trying to contain the fires
and prevent them from reaching more
inhabited areas we're just putting in a
back burn containment line to try and
prevent the fire from heading towards
coastal villages already more than 850
homes have been raised in New South
Wales authorities are also working to
protect infrastructure surrounding a
vital dam west of Sydney that provides
water to around four million people in
the city but which could be at risk if
the fires spread more let's cross over
to journalist Roger Maynard in Sydney
Roger bush fires have been raging around
Sydney for weeks now what effect is this
having on everyday life there well
certainly the bush fires have got
alarmingly close to Sydney within
perhaps an hour to drive from the city
centre so
a bit of a worry for people but the
biggest concern has been the smoke haze
which is blanketed much of New South
Wales now for much of the past fortnight
or so that's obviously dangerous for
people with breathing difficulties it's
dangerous for people with heart problems
and it's also very unpleasant to smell
and to breathe the South even if you're
recently healthy so that's been one of
the big effects of the bush fires in the
cities and of course it's much worse in
the in the countryside and it's the
country people who've really been
suffering for the past few weeks it not
only are all the firefighters putting
themselves at risk but of course the
people generally are worried about
losing their homes and and the threat to
their own lives as well so you know the
whole community has become stressed and
that was a point made by the mayor of
the Blue Mountains earlier on today who
said look this will the stress is
affecting families you know they're
living with the daily threat to their
homes and also the threat to human life
and as you rightly mentioned just now
nine people are so fair dark so far died
in this bushfire crisis and something
about eight or nine hundred homes have
been lost so it's affecting a lot of
people and it permeates throughout the
country many are linking the intensity
of the bush fires to climate change
what's the government's response to that
well there's the sippers debate going on
here about what's caused the drought and
what's caused the climate change which
we're undoubtedly experiencing here
undoubtedly the fires this year have
been much more intense and much more
extensive than they have in in previous
years but the prime minister Scott
Morrison refuses to directly blame any
particular factor for the bushfire sir
he says that you know he's reluctant to
take any firm action against climate
change which might affect the economy
and remember that Australia owns about
sixty billion dollars
year from exports of cold and relies
very heavily to on coal-fired power
stations for electricity so he doesn't
want to do anything that's gonna gonna
harm the economy on the other hand you
have to say that the effect of the smoke
and the fires over the past few weeks
has certainly changed public opinion and
almost certainly Morrison and his
government will come under increasing
pressure to change their mind when it
comes to action on climate change well
Joe thank you very much for you in
science that was journalist Roger
Maynard there in Sydney